PROFESSOR: What did
we have last time?
We had a constant copper
that reflected the energy
so a unit free
version of the energy,
was greater than 0, because we
were looking at bound states,
so the energies were negative.
And we found that this
[INAUDIBLE] this quantized 1
over 2 copper was
N plus l plus 1--
something that we call n.
And n was the principal
quantum number.
So this is the principle
quantum number n
was the degree of a
polynomial in the solution.
And l was an important
quantum number,
because it gave you the
amount of angular momentum
the system had.
And given that we think of it as
principal quantum number coming
first, once you have n and you
fix it because the energy just
depends on n--
Once you fix n,
you'll have that l
can go from 0 up to n minus
1, and those corresponds
to the various
values of capital N.
But we don't have to focus
on it up to n minus 1.
And at the same time in
terms of quantum numbers,
m goes from minus l up to l.
So the order of thinking
is fixed co-- at little m,
and the principal
quantum number.
Then fix an l can go
from up 0 to n minus 1.
Once you fix a little
l, you fix the m.
And m can go from my l to l.
And those are the states
of the hydrogen atom.
The energies in
terms of n are mine
z squared, e squared over
2 knot, 1 over n little n
squared.
And the solutions-- psi nlm
that depend on r theta and phi
were of the form of a
normalization constant, A r
to the l that you can isolate.
That's a behavior for small
r, then a polynomial n r
over a0 of degree,
capital N, which
is n minus L plus 1 times an
exponential decay with radius,
which goes like z over r.
It has to be
dimensionless, the argument
inside the exponential.
And it turns out to
depend on a0, in fact na0
and finally, the
spherical harmonic.
So that was the total solution.
We didn't investigate
the polynomial in detail,
because it takes time.
It's not necessary
for many things.
Only very detailed calculations
require this polynomial.
And it's a Laguerre polynomial.
And if you needed--
if you needed to construct
the quadratic polynomial,
it would be a fight
between looking up
some table of
Laguerre polynomials
and spending time checking
that the conventions they use
are the same than
the ones you choose
versus taking the
recursion relation
and building it up yourself
of the third coefficient.
So that's what it is.
Now the hydrogen atom, there
is a classical description,
a diagram, for the
hydrogen atom and in fact,
for any central potential.
So if you're looking
at bound states,
the way we do bound
states and represent them
for central potentials
is by a diagram
in which you put the energy
on the vertical line.
It's a negative energy.
So you can put 0 in here.
The way the hydrogen atom
works is better, of course,
as usual to use something
dimensionless here.
And the thing we put is
minus 1 over n squared,
the integer the principle
quantum number n minus 1
over n squared,
because this ratio is,
in fact, equal to
the energy divided
by this dimensionless quantity
z squared e squared over 2a0.
So there is n squared,
and the levels go like 1
over n squared, indeed.
So there is minus 1 here,
and then goes to minus 1/4
for n equals 2 minus
1/9 minus 1/16.
And they crowd here.
That's why I don't do
everything in scale.
I cut the scale here, otherwise
the diagram is very long.
And you can put
say the minus 1/4
here, though, 1/9 would be here.
minus 1/9 minus 1/16--
somewhere here.
Those are places where
you have energy levels,
and here it comes.
Let's look at what we can get.
Well, for n equals
1, you're in here.
So what are we going
to plot in this axis.
The idea is to plot
a quantum number.
So actually to say here
is l, but we don't do it
in marking the values of l.
We'll put here l
equals 0 and list
all the states that we get.
So it's like a histogram
or something like that, l
equal 1, l equals 2, equals 3.
And then we put dashes here,
and each dash is a state.
If you look at it and you
say, what's the value of l?
So this corresponds to
the idea that you already
know that if you're solving
a central potential problem,
you have to solve
a radial equation
for different values of l.
Each time another l, l equals
0, l equals 1, l equals 2.
You go on with them.
So m, so when n is equal
to 1, l can be only 0.
So you have 1 states here.
l is equal to 0.
And is equal to 1.
And capital N is
it's equal to 0.
So the only thing that I
cannot read immediately,
I know that n is equal
to 1, because I'm here.
I know that l is equal
to 0, because I'm here.
But I put the extra information,
the capital N equal to 0 here.
And that's it for this level.
So this is that little
n equal 1 level.
Then we go to that
little n equals 2 level.
And when little n is equal to
2, l can be 0, or it can be 1.
When l is equal to
0, capital N would
have to be 1 so that capital N,
which is 1 plus little l, which
is 0 plus 1 is equal to 2.
And this is a level n,
little n equals to 2,
principal quantum
number equal to 2.
So here we have n equals to 2.
Since l is 0, capital N is 1.
Here you have capital
N is equal to 0.
And then we go to the next
level little n equals to 3.
Well, little l can now go
from l equals 0, l equals 1
and l calls 2.
Since little l plus
1 plus capital N
is equal to the
principal quantum number,
here you'll get N equal to 2,
N equals 1, and it goes down,
N equals 0.
These are the states.
Let's do one more.
Little n equals to 4.
And, yes, there's a state
for l equal 0, 1 for equal 1,
1 for equal 2, and this
time we get to l equal 3.
Each time you get
one more l, because l
can go up to n minus 1.
And what is capital N?
Here is 3, 2, 1, and 0.
So this is your diagram.
This is a very nice diagram.
And it has actually is some
sort of mystery in this diagram.
Let me emphasize first one
point that is not mysterious.
It's this growth from an equal
0 to an equal 1 to n equal 2
to n equal 3.
There seems to be
a pattern here.
Here n equals 0, 1.
2.
And it will go up.
So why is that necessary?
Why did that happen?
Remember, that we were solving
a radial equation, which
was like a
one-dimensional potential.
And if you are solving a
one-dimensional potential,
the node theorem works.
So there should be no
nodes for the ground state.
And the fact that the wave
function vanishes at r equals 0
is not a node,
because that's the end
of the world at r equals 0.
But then you're solving
this radial equation.
And let's look at
this polynomial.
Well, you're not going to
get a 0 of the wave function,
because of this factor.
It's an overall factor.
And the exponential never
vanishes just at infinity,
but never doesn't
vanish at the point.
So all the 0's of
the wave function
have to arise from
this polynomial.
And there shouldn't be any
0 for the ground state.
So good.
N equal 0 means no nodes
here, no nodes for the--
this is a different problem.
This is an l equals 1.
It's again a new potential.
So you solve the
radial equation again.
Yes, the ground state, when l is
equal to 1 must have no nodes.
So you should, remember, you're
solving the radial question.
One's here for one potential,
here for another potential,
because the effective
potential depends on l, here
for another potential.
There for another potential.
So each time, it's a new
one-dimensional problem,
which must have a
ground state and a state
with 1 node, which is
possible, because a degree 1
polynomial has one 0.
A degree two polynomial
can have two 0's.
Why it has another
degree n polynomial
may have n 0's But
it may have less
0's if the 0's are complex.
But if better be that this
polynomials don't do that,
because they would
violate the known theorem.